My opponent tonight
is Karamo Brown,
one of the stars
of the Netflix show, Queer Eye.
If he thinks he's going
to get me to cry tonight,
he's gonna have
to dig real deep.
Or just mention my dad.
Karamo Brown, everybody.
-Hey! -Karamo, welcome. Welcome.
-(cheering and applause)
-So, your father...
-Please, don't...
-Can we... can we wait?
Can we wait? -Okay. We'll wait.
We'll wait,
we'll wait, we'll wait.
But do you know something?
Does he love me?
I do.
-We will get to that.
-Okay, okay.
-'Cause that's a Pandora's box,
all right? -Yes.
And that she-devil's box,
you do not want to open.
-I want to talk about your show.
-Yes.
Queer Eye. Now, the Fab Five,
uh, you shoot a lot of this
in Georgia,
-which is a red state.
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Is this goal of this show
transforming Trump's America
to become more liberal?
Is that your end goal?
No!
-Okay, that...
-Okay. (laughs)
No, our-our goal
is definitely not to change, uh,
you know, the red states pink,
you know?
We just want to make sure
that they open their hearts
-a little bit. -So you-you w...
you're going out there
-to try to change parts
of America. -Yeah.
Well, no, we're not trying
to change parts of America.
We're trying to make people
feel better about who they are
so that, hopefully,
they'll change themselves.
How do you have the hard
conversation with yourself
so you can have a hard
conversation with other people?
How do you have a hard
conversation with yourself?
Well, let's start
with your father.
-Please, okay, let's...
That was... -Okay?
How do you have a
hard conversation with yourself?
-We start with my father.
-You start with your...
-It-it all starts there.
-It starts from the top down.
-Yeah. Uh-huh. -You-you are...
You cover culture.
-Yes. -Now, that's something
I've never been that into.
-(laughs) -What do you mean...
When you walk in there
with a focus on culture,
what are you talking about?
So, culture is actually
a misleading title, you know?
My goal is actually to fix
the inside.
My background is in social work,
psychotherapy.
So it's all about figuring out
what's blocking you
and what's stopping you
from talking to people
or being curious about life.
And that's where,
really, my goal is.
That's why you see the tears.
It's...
I break them down on the inside.
How do... how do you make
somebody... how...
-Now, that's something
I'm interested in. -Yeah, okay.
How do you break a person down
from the inside?
-Exactly.
-How do you get at the tears?
How-how do you make somebody
cry?
I've just been watching
Republicans all week,
-so that's how I usually do it.
Yeah. -Yes, yes?
I just follow their format.
Yeah.
'Cause I have been crying
since this election started.
-There's been a lot of tears
on television. -Yes, definitely.
Well, stuff has shifted.
The... Uh, Queer Eye
-for the Straight Guy
started in 2003. -Yes.
-Queer Eye is now
15 years later. -Uh-huh.
Well, how is this show
different?
How is it approached
differently?
How have times changed,
in that sense?
Um, well...
How have times changed?
-Well, there was a Bush
in office the first time. -Yeah.
Now there's a-an ass in office.
-So, yeah. -We've made...
we've made America great again.
Uh... (stammers)
Perspective, right?
-Sure. -I think what
we're really trying to hope
and trying to figure out, like,
why do you all keep trying
to change everything, you know?
I liked the country
we had beforehand.
And I think
what we want people to see
is that there's a beauty in
the country that was here once
-and we don't need to change it.
-There's been
-some interesting moments on
your show as well. -Yes. Yeah.
-Uh, there was one
when you were in Georgia, -Yes.
uh, and-and you had a sit-down
with a police officer.
What's happen...
what happened there?
Well, he is a Trump supporter,
a police officer,
and we had a very transparent
conversation about what it is
to be a black man, for me,
a gay man in America,
with the militarization
of police officers.
And it was really beautiful,
because two people
who normally don't have
a dialogue came together
and found common ground
in the fact that we are fathers,
in the fact
that we are proud Americans,
in the fact that we want to see
our country be the best
-that it can be. -Why do you
think people are being draw...
uh, drawn to Queer Eye? It's had
a lot of popularity recently.
Uh, what is it about the show
that sticks out
that people want to watch?
Uh, as... I-I'm... I wish
you could tell me months ago,
-uh, what that secret could be.
Uh... -(laughing)
But what do you...
what do you think the nugget is
inside of a show like that,
-where people would tune in
regularly? -It's-it's funny,
-'cause I tune in regularly
to you, so... -I'll take that.
-I'll take... -You actually have
it all. It's the good hair,
good clothes, pretty eyes,
and being open to America.
-This is... this is... Y...
-(cheering and applause)
Are you crying?
So, that message
was actually from your father.
I see... Oh, don't...
Karamo, you be careful.
-I s... I see your wicked ways.
-Yes. Exactly.
Why do you think
this resonates in 2018?
Really, it's because, uh,
we're at a time right now
where a lot of people feel
very divided and disconnected.
They don't feel like people are
talking to each other anymore.
And this is an opportunity
for people to realize
that we're more alike
than we are different.
And that's what's most important
in all of this.
-You're political also outside
the show. -I am. Very political.
-Wha-What are your passions?
-Um, my passions vary
from comprehensive
gun control...
I was a-a graduate of,
uh, Marjory Stoneman Douglas
in Parkland, Florida.
I'm also a father.
And to see these children die
at the hands of guns,
it's not about taking guns away
from Americans--
it's about
how can we work together
-to protect our children. -Do
you have political aspirations?
Um, you know what,
I-I would say this.
Ronald Reagan was, you know,
a Californian man,
and he also was president.
Trump was a reality star,
and he's president.
I don't know.
Maybe one day, you know,
there could be a gay,
black governor of California.
(cheering and applause)
Could that be the change
America needs?
You think Californians
would vote for a liberal?
(laughing)
Tell me something
I already know.
Um, that Donald Trump
is probably the greatest
magician we have ever seen.
That sleight of hand-- he tricks
you over here and says,
"Look, I'm changing immigration.
"I'm gonna repeal
what I just done with all...
"tearing apart
all these families,
"while I'm also pulling us out
of the U.N.
and, um, the human rights."
And so I think that's something
that we should
really be focusing on
is that this greatest magician
is trying to pull the wool
over our eyes.
And we now know there's a man
behind the curtain,
and we're not gonna take it
anymore.
He shows you the big hand,
-he grabs you with the other.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I hear that.
A new season of Queer Eye
is now available on Netflix.
Karamo Brown.